Can we, can we talk about the real masterpiece airing the season though?
Oh, I'm Joey. Joey knows what I'm talking about.
I was just about to bring it up. I so, so forget it.
Forget this attack on Titans Lando,
or like whatever we're going to call the classic.
The real classic that's coming out the season is an anime called X arm.
So I'm a, I'm a complete newb. Now I have seen clips of it,
but can you please explain to me what arm is and it's totally,
it is hilarious. It is, um, experience.
I will say that. So I think we have literally got the mass effect,
Andromeda releases of anime. You know what I mean? Cyber punk finish.
So this is, I didn't know, anime could have bugs and glitches.
That's all I'm going to say.
So is a crunchy roll original, right? And you know,
that crunchy roll up proud of this because I have not seen a single piece of
promotional work about this.
I saw the trailer on YouTube and I thought it was Joe and
the show looks worse than that. It looks,
it looks worse than I hate to say to you about the trailers.
Probably the best part about the show, the trailer isn't the trailer.
The trailer is the animal that makes it good. Doesn't it? But it's so bad.
I was crying and laughter the first episodes is like,
I think the third lowest anime. Well,
right now it is one episode of the one episode you're laughing.
So it's a that's that's what,
it's a masterpiece of trash basically. It's it's masterpiece.
It is a Mark. It's like, it's like the first time I watch like Gazi swing,
right? Yeah. All like, you know, helped us give.
And I was like a scale to heaven. I was like, this is,
I'm watching a masterpiece, but on the opposite. End of the so, so to,
to explain ex-army there's a control original anime, um,
that is made by a completely new studio by a team who's never worked in anime
before American, no Japanese Japanese team,
but they've never worked an animate before and it shows, okay. It shows,
it shows that they've never worked anatomy before. Um,
it is a 3d anime that looks like it was made by a
five-year-old who just learned blender like yesterday. Um, it,
it makes Ruby look like it makes Ruby season one looked like an app's like
master. I was going to watch it,
but I just wanted to get like drunk enough just to like fully enjoy it.
[inaudible] 2016 looked like a Kira. You know what I mean? Yeah.
It's pretty bad.
And what's worse is that like I posted the clip of it on Twitter,
but like there's a scene right near the beginning where the main character is
3d, but his brother is in 2d white.
So you have this truly awful CG,
like blocky, Minecraft character starting next to this 2d anime character.
He literally in the same scene in the same shot. And he literally looks,
he looks green screened on, you know what I mean?
It looks like someone just learned,
it looked like someone just had learned this, the chromic he's like, yo,
you heard of this thing called a chroma key X.
You can see it on screen right now. God that's awful.
You know what that is? That's like, that looks like if you told me that was, uh,
what's that, uh,
what's that game where everyone can have their own avatars in the game.
It looks like the like second life, whatever it's called, it looks like if like,
you know how,
like someone other people have their own servers and they have like 2d things
and they have like the 3d models. That's what it looks.
You know what that looks like.
That looks like someone took like a regular animate and made like an MMD edit of
it. I can see it. Cause it is like that quality
[inaudible] on my MMD. And then like, if, if that wasn't already bad,
there was just like some of the fight choreography is just hilarious.
Like this is one fight scene.
I think like it's like the last fight scene of the first episode where there was
just no music. It's like, they forgot to put in the music. It's just like,
like that, but there's no music whatsoever. So it's just,
I was watching it and I was just like,
there's something wrong with my headphones? Like why is there no music playing?
I remember like in the last fight they, they run out or something.
And it's literally a guy who looks like it looks like it. Literally,
it looks like the characters are like being animated with a stick or something
like that. There's literally no,
like they're not moving their limbs or something.
They're just like rocking from side to side. So are we talking that like that,
like queen bee would put them to shame. Oh,
I wish this was out of Macy by queen. It makes queen bee look like studio weird.
It's horrible. Yeah. But it's also just a really fun time.
Like I had a lot of fun watching the first episode. I mean,
I want to get some drinks and just enjoy it, you know? Oh, we need to,
this would be like even better if it had like kind of like a ghost stories,
dub it's like someone needs to dub Exxon, like crunchy roll, please.
Don't be ashamed of XRM. You are sitting on a golden duck here just,
just marketed correctly. And people will mean the out of us.
The rights to Dobbin, Waldoboro, dove. It all make an amazing double bed.
You know what I mean? Can't wait to direct those sessions
and like the opening song as well. Just what is that?
The one that sounds like some, some 41. It sounds like, it sounds like a,
some 41 cover band. I heard that was the one that used for the trailer, right?
Yeah. That is just the animation tied to sent me it. And he's like, what the is
[inaudible] yeah. What the? What is this? God. It's like,
it's like a high school band that listened to too much green day.
You know what I mean?
It does sound like a cover band. Oh my God. That is perfect.
But so why is no one talking about that?
You have a tackling type of season four, but who gives a about how,
who greenlit that? Like, I know, sorry. Like who,
who let that through like quality assurance?
Like who led that through what qualities of what I'm saying?
Like there's normally people who are like, yeah, this is good to go. Who,
who dead watched that first episode was like, yeah, it's good. I wonder though,
if someone at like the production team was like,
I feel like we're forgetting something QA. Oh. Sometimes when like,
people like make shows, but it's just one big like tax fraud, scheme.
What a fruit slide. I shouldn't say that I could get in trouble.
It's definitely a joke. It's a joke, you know, just saying,
Oh my God. But like, I wonder what the people working on it think of this,
you know what I mean? Cause you know, sometimes,
sometimes you work on a project that you're proud about.
You know what I mean? Because
people want to get paid God at the end of the day. They're like, I mean,
I got to just keep turning up and doing what they ask. Right.
That's what I imagined happening. I don't know.
I just like to imagine that like the animators came back to the,
like the produce and was like, yeah. Th th the models look great. Um,
so like put some shading on there,
put a little more animation on the producer's light.
So it's coming out tomorrow. I just want, I just want to know, because you know,
and like in any like anime production or any big project production, you know,
you have this, you have this screening nights, right? Where you as a group,
as the team, you get to watch the final product before it airs.
I just want to hear the silence in that room when the credits roll and
you just, you just want, what can you say, psych in Japan,
it's always silent.
That's what I see in America and the West. We have clapping.
I just liked the thing that the entire like screening room is just like silently
nodding their head. They're like, hell yeah, everyone knows every Japanese man,
just waiting for the [inaudible]. Anyway, come on. I want to be a man, the
screening and free drinks. So it doesn't matter like that, that turning
up to the screen. I turn up to the screening. If I get free meal at the end of it, listen, man, like as someone who's like, you know,
done a documentary in anatomy studio, I completely [inaudible]
. I get it. It's hard, but also come on. It's hard. But come on, man. It's hard. You know, we're not, we're not blaming the
problem at all
. I'm not blaming anyone for it. If anything, I'd like to thank them for giving us
something like quality entertainment. Honestly, it is
honestly quality. I didn't say I, I watched episode two and it is also a banger. Just coming out with
an episode, man. XR episode two is one I'm looking forward to.